اعتاد إيفان أن يعيش في شارع السلام في ماريوبول ،
فأنت تريد أن تظل مدينتك كما
كانت في ذاكرتك ، أخبرني
أن المدينة تقع الآن في أنقاض قذيفة
مما كانت عليه من قبل
وأن مصنع الصلب الذي
كرسته عائلته ثلاثة أجيال
فجأة  يجد نفسه على أنه
خط دفاع ماريوبول الأخير الذي
يرى أن مدينتك يتم تدميرها أمر
مروع يخبرني
أنه يمكنك مقارنته بأحد أقاربك الذي يموت
بين ذراعيك ورؤيته أو عضوها يحتضر
تدريجياً بعد فشل العضو ولا
يمكنك فعل أي شيء
لزميله أليكسي إنه
شخصيًا أيضًا ، لم يخسر أصدقاءه
فحسب ، بل حماته
بسبب القصف عندما حاولوا أولاً
الفرار من ماريوبول ،
كيف يجعلك هذا تشعر أنك
غاضب جدًا ،
اختفت مشاعري بالفعل هناك في
ماريوبول ، كما يقول ، ولهذا السبب لا يوجد
شيء سوى الكراهية
عمل alexi في مصنع الصلب لمدة
26 عامًا ،
وهو واحد من 11000 موظف
حافظوا على أفران الحديد التي تحولت هنا
إلى مسرحية رئيسية في صناعة المعادن حيث أن
الأسلوب ينتج fou.  مليون طن من
الفولاذ
سنويًا لمعادنها اللامعة في
ساحات هدسون في مانهاتن وشظايا لندن
الآن حيث تضرب روسيا مصنعها ويهز الإنتاج لتوقف
الرئيس التنفيذي للشركة التي تقف وراء ستار
ستيل ، كما أخبرني أن 150 من موظفيه على الأقل
كانوا  قُتل وما
زال الآلاف في عداد المفقودين
من أصل 11000 موظف في الوقت الحالي ،
فقط
حوالي 4.5000 شخص
خرجوا من ماريوبول
وتواصلوا معنا ،
هذا هو مصنعنا حيث يقول أبي إنه
يعمل هنا وتقول ابنته الصغيرة في  تم هدم
مقطع فيديو ترويجي تم
إنشاؤه في عام 1933 في ظل الحكم
السوفياتي بشكل جزئي خلال
الاحتلال النازي في الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
وهو الآن يواجه غضب الرئيس
الذي يقول إنه ينتهكه
ويهاجم الأساس الذي
ساعدت بلاده
في بنائه المختبئين في الداخل.
يختبئ حوالي ألف مدني في ملاجئ
النساء والأطفال وكبار السن الذين
لم يروا ضوء الشمس منذ أكثر من 50
يومًا
ثم هناك الجرحى في
المستشفيات الميدانية.  تستمر هذه
القوات الروسية في تطويق
المصنع وهم لا يقومون بالتجميع ، لا
أعتقد أنه أه هي الخطة التي
يريدها أعتقد أنه
يدور حول رمزية الفوز في مدينة ماريوبول الساحلية من شأنه أن
يوفر للرئيس بوتين جسرًا بريًا
إلى شبه جزيرة القرم في أوكرانيا
التي ضمتها روسيا في عام 2014.
إذا تم الاستيلاء على رينات أحمدوف بالكامل ، فقد أخبرني أحد
أغنى رجال أوكرانيا
والمساهم الرئيسي في المجموعة وراء
ستار ستيل ، عبر البريد الإلكتروني ،
لن تعمل هذه المصانع تحت الاحتلال الروسي تحت أي ظرف من الظروف.
بعد ما لم يفعلوه
أبدًا جدار من الصلب يدافع حتى النهاية المريرة
عن المكان الذي يسمونه بالمنزل
إيزا سوارا CNN ليفيث أوكرانيا
أنت